[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Network
Intelligence Center
is Google Cloud's
solution for network
monitoring across the
cloud and on premise.
It improves user experience,
security, and operations
by providing a comprehensive
platform for monitoring,
visualizing, and troubleshooting
network health across the cloud
and data center.
Connectivity Tests is a module
in Network Intelligence Center
that enables you to do
network verification, which
is a key part of
intent-based networking.
The idea of verification
is to ensure
that the intent of the
network designer is being met.
It also allows you
to move from reactive
to proactive network operations
by predicting what could happen
when you make a config change,
thus preventing network
outages.
Published sources show
that 75% of network outages
and performance issues happen
due to misconfiguration.
In a complex Google
Cloud environment
with a shared VPC, many
firewall rules and routes,
it can be difficult to quickly
identify which configuration
caused the connectivity issue.
Connectivity Test enables
a user to test connectivity
between a source and
destination end point.
It also tells you
if the connectivity
is broken and identifies the
root cause, such as a firewall
rule or route config.
Connectivity Test performs a
static reachability analysis
by building a model
of the network
and then doing packet
simulation on the network based
on configuration.
Let's see how you can use
on-demand connectivity tests
with the help of three
different examples.
Say you've run into connectivity
issues between two VM instances
in different zones in a project.
You can check the connectivity
between source and destination
endpoint by creating
a connectivity test.
Click on Create
Connectivity Test.
Pick the protocol ICMP.
Select a source VM instance or
an IP address, pick VPC1 US VM,
and a destination VM
instance slash IP address.
Pick VPC1 EU VM,
and click Create.
This saves the test
and also runs it.
Once the test is run, it shows
Test Result as Unreachable.
Click on View to check
the result details.
It shows you a detailed
hop-by-hop trace,
showing how the packet would
traverse through the network.
From the trace, you can see the
packet starts from the source
VM, goes through an
egress firewall rule,
and then the packet gets
dropped by the ingress firewall
rule at the destination VM.
You can click any of the hops
to see more details of the hop.
Here, if you click
Ingress Firewall Rule,
you can see that the
Deny ICMP Firewall
rule blocked the connectivity.
Right from here, you can go
to the firewall rule page,
update or disable
the firewall rule.
Let's disable the
firewall rule and check
if this fixes the issue.
Select the test, and run
the connectivity test again
to verify the impact of
your firewall rule change
and make sure
connectivity is restored.
After you rerun, the
Test Result shows
Reachable, which tells you
that the connectivity issue is
fixed.
Notice how easy it was to
quickly understand the trace,
find out the root
cause, firewall rule,
and update it, and analyze
whether it fixes the problem?
Let's look at a more
complex scenario
where there are
two VPCs connected
via high-availability VPN.
AJ VPN creates two
tunnels to provide
four nines of availability.
We'll test connectivity between
a VM in VPC1 connected to a VM
in VPC2 via HA VPN.
Click on Create
Connectivity Test
and pick the protocol TCP,
source and destination VM,
and click Create.
It shows Test Result
as Unreachable.
Click on View to see the trace.
In this case, you
can see there are
two traces, which is
expected, since this path is
through HA VPN.
Connectivity Test will show you
multiple traces if they exist.
From this trace, you can see
that there is a VPN gateway,
and the traffic is getting
dropped at the ingress firewall
rule VPC2, Deny HTTP.
You can go to the
Firewall Rules page
and fix or disable
the firewall rule.
Let's disable it
and rerun the test.
And you can now see that the
connectivity is restored.
You can also check the second,
trace to analyze the path
and make sure both the
tunnels are set up correctly,
You can also verify connectivity
between Google Cloud
and on-prem, or on-prem
to Google Cloud, which
could be especially useful
during application migration.
Here we are checking
the connectivity
between the VM instance on
GCP and an external on-prem IP
address.
Click on Create Connectivity
Test, select Protocol, ICMP,
source VM instance as VPC1 US
VM, and destination IP address.
Once the test
finishes, you can see
Test Result shows
Reachable, which
means the connectivity is OK.
You can click on View and
look at the path trace
to better understand
your network design.
In this case, you
can see the traces
going through a NAT gateway
and can reach the external IP
address.
As a user, you can
create and save
multiple connectivity tests
that reflect your intent,
connectivity that
should be allowed,
and those that
should be blocked.
Here, you can see we
have created and saved
a few different tests.
Anytime you make a
configuration change,
you can run these tests
to verify the impact
of your configuration changes.
For some tests,
the intent might be
to have connectivity
between the endpoints,
so you'll see those
test results in green.
For other tests,
the intent might
be to block connectivity
between the endpoints,
so those test results
should be in red.
Anytime you make a
configuration change,
you can run these tests to make
sure your intent stays intact.
Connectivity Test
provides you a quick way
to do network
verification and ensure
that any configuration change
does not violate your intent.
It allows you to treat
your configuration as code,
and you can think of
these as unit tests
that you can run to
prevent network outages
and also verify your security
slash compliance posture.
Congratulations.
You're all set up to start
using the Connectivity Test
module in network
Intelligence Center
to do network verification,
quickly diagnose
connectivity issues due
to misconfiguration,
and predict the impact
of configuration changes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]